So what are the steps involved
in these types of projects?
Before you jump in and
write a fancy algorithm,
you'll want to spend some time
getting familiar with your data.
The process begins with
a question you want to answer or
a problem you want to solve.
This might be something like,
what are the characteristics of
students who pass their projects?
Or how can I better stock my store with
the products people most want to buy?
The next step of the process
is data wrangling and
this really has two parts,
data acquisition and data cleaning.
First, you need to acquire the data
that you need to answer your question or
solve your problem.
Then it's time to begin
investigating the data and
cleaning up any problems that you find.
The third phase is data exploration.
During this phase, you spend some
time getting familiar with your data,
building your intuition about it and
finding patterns.
Once you're familiar with your data,
you'll usually want to draw some
conclusions about it or
maybe make some predictions.
>From one of our examples previously,
Netflix's movie recommendation systems
needs to predict which
movies its users will like.
Also the Facebook paper we saw concluded
that users are less likely to click
certain articles, specifically one's
written from a different ideological
perspective than the user has.
This phase usually involves statistics
or machine learning that are beyond
the scope of this course, but
there are additional Udacity courses
you can take on these topics,
if you're interested learning more.
And finally, you'll need to communicate
your findings to other people.
Your findings are only as useful as
your ability to communicate them.
Even if your end goal is to
build some sort of system,
like a movie recommender or
a news feed ranking algorithm,
you'll usually need to share what you've
built and how it works with your team.
There are a variety of formats
this communication can take.
You might write a blog post,
a paper, an email,
a PowerPoint presentation, or
just have an in-person conversation.
Data visualization is a common
technique that's almost always useful
when communicating findings about data.
Now, this process doesn't
actually follow a straight line.
Especially the data wrangling phase and
to the data exploration phase
are very intertwined because you can't
really clean any problems with the data
before you take a look to
see what problems there are.
And even when you think you're done
wrangling and you're ready to just
explore, you'll keep finding more
problems and have to go back.
Throughout the process, you may
need to return to your question and
refine it as you become more
familiar with the data set.
And sometimes data acquisition actually
comes before you pose a question.
If a new, exciting data set is released,
you might acquire the data first,
take a look and see what's there, and
then think of some questions
you could answer with the data.
That's what we'll be
doing in this lesson.
However, this should give you an idea of
the high level steps that are involved
when you're doing data analysis.